single favorite technique to use in
persuasion because it allows me to be
even more honest than i otherwise would
be it's using the word but and this is
the concept of damaging admission so
let's say i said you're going to make a
ton of money if you work with me but
it's going to be a ton of work there's
gonna be hundreds of hours of videos
you're gonna have to go through five
hours a day that you're gonna have to
spend to execute each of the things that
i'm gonna tell you to do what happens is
in that statement i directed your
attention to all of the things that
you're going to have to do if you
noticed it was positive statement but
negative statement now if you reverse
these things negative statement but
positive statement the butt acts as an
amplifier for the second half let's try
it on listen if you sign up to work with
me you're gonna have to go through
hundreds of hours of videos you're gonna
have to take five hours a day to work
and do these things but you're gonna
make more money than ever in your life
so the good thing is you can actually
control where your prospect's attention
is going so this is where we're
directing them it's after the word but